so we had something pretty amazing
happened to us recently the artist
beeple came into the studio to teach us
about nfts and crypto art because he
just before this interview had sold some
of his works for three and a half
million dollars which had blown his mind
blown our minds and totally brought the
world of crypto nfts roaring to life in
the public eye now little did we know
that since we recorded that interview
people would go on to become the third
most profitable living artist on this
planet when he sold a collage of 5 000
of his everydays for 70 million dollars
as crypto art so what the heck is crypto
art what the heck are rfts well we had
no idea so he sat down with us to teach
us and you so in this video you're going
to watch an almost unedited interview
where we get the knowledge straight from
the man himself about what the heck is
going on
in this world of digital art also uh
people have some very colorful language
so i'm sorry about all the beeping if
you want to watch the video with all of
his wonderful swear words intact you can
watch it on the website all right now on
to the
video
let's kick things off so i think the
very first thing that everyone's going
to ask is what is crypto art crypto art
think of it just as like proof of
ownership of like a piece of artwork the
blockchain the reason bitcoins have
value is because
you can't copy a bitcoin you can't just
take one bitcoin and like okay i took
one now i've got two i'm sweet i just
doubled my money like that's not how
bitcoin works so that's why bitcoin has
value and so that's the same thing with
this you can prove that you own a piece
of art be it a jpeg be it a mp4 be it a
wav file whatever
and everybody else agrees so one of the
arguments it's like well what if i just
screenshotted it or like recorded the
screen you can do that but nobody else
is going to agree that you own it and
because it's coming from you the artist
it's like kind of like signing the piece
when you sort of like mint the like
token or whatever so
again anybody else can mint anything but
it's like some random person is like i
own this picture it'll be like okay no
people owns that picture like you know
if somebody tried to mint one of your
you know boston dynamics videos or
something like that it'd be like okay
well clearly corridor digital owns the
video like what are you talking about
you don't own it so it's like a
certificate of authenticity it's a
certificate of authenticity and plus
it's sort of like tied to the artist
themselves so my question is does the
actual image itself get encoded into the
blockchain absolutely not because what
when you encode something on the
blockchain it's very big
it takes up a lot of space and a lot of
like gas to mint that because that's
what people are getting paid for to like
mine and stuff like that so
images take up a lot of space and would
be like
way way too big to actually embed in the
the blockchain there are some people who
embed very simple like vector images
into the blockchain and there's some
interesting projects around that but
most of the stuff is actually on a
decentralized file server called ipfs
and it's stored there and just
referenced from the blockchain in
bitcoin you know you have people who are
mining and if i'm not mistaken
a miner with like cryptocurrencies
basically somebody that's just letting
their computer update the blockchain
across the blockchain verify
transactions on the blockchain so
where how does mining work with crypto
art because you can generate bitcoins
from your mining but you don't just
necessarily generate art ownership yup
so you don't really mind with this stuff
you mint tokens and it's basically
you're saying like i want to add this
token to the blockchain it's usually
done through a platform you just upload
the picture like the ones that let you
just mint whenever you want like super
rare you just like fill out a little
form and just say i want to add some
artwork to the blockchain
it takes a little bit of actual money
it's called gas fees to actually mint it
and it'll take a couple minutes and then
it's like boom it's on blockchain and
now it's like
officially on the like blockchain for
like everybody so it's kind of like
there's so it's kind of interesting that
there's a lot more like sort of like
finality to it that it's like no matter
where like everybody sort of like agrees
that's that token now as part of the
blockchain and once you've minted that
project or that picture you cannot edit
it ever again so if you make a typo in
the title of that picture it's stuck
that way forever not unless you
programmed your it to be able to allow
you to do that which you could but even
that would cause gas fees to like change
the like pointer and stuff like better
updates yeah can you explain gas the gas
fees are just sort of like if you want
to mint something it's what you're
paying the miners to sort of like add to
the thing it's not sort of that much of
a piece of it it costs somewhere between
it could be from 10 to like a hundred
dollars or something so like when you
put gas into a car it's also kind of
like putting gas into a blockchain
transaction it's sort of like what pays
to add your thing because then otherwise
anybody could add anything to the
blockchain and again everybody's sort of
like agreeing on this thing so
if you just started adding a bunch of
junk to it
this kind of stops that because it's
like well you can add whatever you want
but it's expensive to add
so
you're a little bit more sort of like
careful about like what you're sort of
like adding to it
hey there i just wanted to quickly
address an issue that is blown up
surrounding the environmental impact of
nfts there's a lot of outrage right now
about how they're ruining the
environment you may have seen the
headlines the concern is valid it's a
big concern of mine as well the problem
comes from the fact that the current
blockchain protocols waste a lot of
energy however nft's role in this is
complex the short answer is that nfts
and by extension the artists making them
are not actually the problem the current
way the blockchain operates is the
problem and would be a problem
regardless of whether or not nfts even
existed they are not directly making the
problem worse this topic honestly
deserves a deep dive so i've decided to
make a dedicated video interviewing
experts so that we can all get a better
idea of the real issues the
misunderstood arguments floating around
right now have unfortunately led to a
lot of harassment targeted at the
artists in this space and that's just
unfair listen i hear you there are a lot
of valid criticisms of nfts but none of
them justify getting angry at the
artists
so before you pick up your amazon one
day delivered pitchforks to accuse
artists of ruining the environment
please i implore you to consider where
your outrage might be better placed so
how much of this isn't about the art and
more about the investment in a person
well i would say personally say it is a
lot about the investment in a person
because again a lot of this art you can
see on instagram most of it you can see
or or almost all of it you can see if
you go to these crypto art sites or
whatever and again there's a bunch of
platforms if you just enjoy looking at
the art like you don't need to spend
hundreds or you know potentially
thousands of dollars to sort of like do
that you can just look at the art so
it is a bit more of kind of like a
speculation thing a bit more like fine
art and you would think like okay am i
going to buy this is it going to
appreciate in value at least i would be
hoping people are thinking about that
when they're spending thousands of
dollars on these things like is this
going to retain the value unless you are
just like i really want to support this
artist which some people are like
they're really just like
i love this art it speaks to me this or
that like i just want to like
own this and feel like i'm supporting
the artist so
it's it's kind of it is however you sort
of like look at it ultimately like it's
an investment you're going to put your
money into the stock and it's going to
go up and you're going to trade it and
flip it
well it's not necessarily going to go up
though that's the thing yeah for sure
people that it is a risk anytime you're
doing that because you could have say
you there's an artist you really like
and they put out something and then they
just stop making art probably in 15
years that person art will you know
unless it was a really sort of like
special piece that stood out for some
reason maybe it won't be worth anything
so there's definitely risks here that
it's like especially if you're putting
down significant sums of money like you
really need to think about like
is this an artist that i think like long
term or it depends on why you're buying
it if you're just buying it to flip it
or something like that then you know it
could be different and that's the thing
i think people don't understand about
these
as well that these sort of marketplaces
kind of like exist
just like ebay or something like that
you can buy something and then
immediately sell it right through the
site and so you could sell it for more
or you could sell it for less but it's
all sort of like a closed system right
there that can like
facilitate these transactions really
quickly can you explain the difference
between traditional like art museum
style marketplace versus the crypto art
marketplace and how uh the key
difference there is the royalty fee yeah
there's a couple differences between the
sort of traditional art marketplace and
the crypto arc marketplace one of them
is if you're talking about pure like
digital nfts that have no
sort of physical component they can be
traded very fast what does nft say nft
stands for non-fungible token it means
sort of like token that can't be
kind of like broken or sort of like and
the word is fungible okay which is a
weird word
fungible so yeah one you can instantly
transfer stuff so things can be a bit
more liquid like anybody in the world
can immediately you know if you have a
painting or like a print or something
like that it's a bit slower to sort of
like sell it whereas this you know if
it's digital can be very fast yeah i
think the the other thing like you were
saying is the royalties there is a uh
you know 10 royalties that that sort of
follows the pieces around so that's
another like big advantage over the
traditional art market so
every time someone has a transaction
with your piece you're still getting
paid for it
so yeah
most of the the sort of like rule of
thumb on most of these platforms is 10
so
i sold it and there was a couple things
that i did to sort of like play with
that uh on the drops that i didn't and
and some of the sites sort of like
structured it so that anybody can
release anything at any time and some of
them have them sort of like centered
around these drops where people release
a collection of artwork like three or
four pieces in different ways some of it
will be
auctions some of it could be like open
editions where it's on sale for like you
know just a few minutes or something
very small like that or it could be
limited editions where it's like this is
like a one of ten so there's a bunch of
different ways to sort of like buy this
stuff as well so you just mentioned
having an open edition where 100 people
can buy it so you don't have to have
just one owner of a piece of art you can
have multiple people owning a piece of
art definitely you can definitely have
multiple people own a piece of art so
you can sort of split it up however you
like you could have it be a one of one a
single edition or you could also have it
be a one of ten or just an open edition
where it's however many people buy it in
you know five minutes that's how many
people own it and they all own the same
thing and they're numbered freaking
warhol prices yeah so it's sort of like
and they have different values and
people can put them up for sale for like
different amounts so it definitely
creates some very different dynamics
just based on the like edition numbers
as well so like you purchase a piece
like this and the token effectively goes
into your wallet yep exactly so like
your wallet that you use for purchasing
things here there but then it's also
containing effectively items yes
those items are just items
the value is whatever the it is when you
go to salvation it could be you don't
know how much it is until you go to be
like hey
anybody want to buy this token and
everybody's like
no then your thing is worth zero yeah
versus if everybody if you put it up for
an auction and everybody's like holy sh
i'm freaking boners on that token i want
that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like there should be some long
blizzards like
there's a bleep off my mouth can you
give us a custom holy [ __ ] mother baby
how long have you been messing with this
so i have only been in this crypto space
for like three months it has been
literally since mid-october
um but i have like just dove head first
just because it's been so interesting to
me and there's so many
so many possibilities and like now
bringing in the like physical aspects
and like designing you know product
design industrial design um
and all that it's just been such an
inspiring space and like you know
obviously making a ton of money really
helps that too
we're being totally honest there's some
tip for the kids
so this is a box
as a way to display the nfts okay
something that people get with the nfts
as sort of like a way to
passively enjoy the like digital artwork
in your like household in a way that
kind of wasn't possible before so uh we
put together this thing through you know
a bunch of different vendors
that it's like
a um
thing and it's got a bunch of
weird stuff in there it's got hair
circles some of this stuff yeah
it comes with a cleaning cloth and like
yeah so here's the uh the pieces
yeah wait so is that just like a monitor
completely encased in
glass looks like a monster each one has
a signed numbered titanium backplate
what i see is like a bunch of people
like collecting these like it moves yeah
dude it's a video
uh the qr code on there
if you go to the qr code that brings up
this website that i made
peoplecollect.com and immediately see
like more information on it the edition
size view it on the blockchain this will
be like it's right now it's like a
behind the scenes like you know of how
it was made so trying to build like a
community around like owning these
things and like that's what i i feel
like a bunch of people are going to do
this and yeah you'll own like a bunch of
these things now i think they're having
a super cool idea this looks so special
man this is amazing it's really cool
because you are literally the premier
like crypto artist right now you're on
top of the entire game right now so how
does that feel it is very picked up if
i'm being honest there's a they're
playing for it yeah it's super weird
because it's just
again being so new to it like it's very
surreal because it happened especially
in this like coveted time where it's
just like you know
it's just such a
like what is going on 2020 was already
weird as hell and then it's like this on
top of it it's just
super super out of nowhere but yeah
there's just so many possibilities and
everybody in the space is just very
welcoming and very like passionate about
it like it's it's one of those things
where once you kind of like dive in
people aren't kind of like half like
people just freaking go head first and
then it's
uh real quick you just want to talk
about how you mentioned the investor and
the artist on the same team and how cool
that is versus the opposite so one of
the like things that's really there's a
lot of things that are super different
about this than the like sort of like
freelance world that a lot of like you
know
people in our industry are like from you
know you have a client they have a
problem you solve the problem and like
that's it they pay you money and you
decide all that beforehand and it is
what it is
um
this obviously is you make whatever the
hell you want and then you're just like
oh does anybody want to buy this like
it's just a super different dynamic and
so
you know to be quite honest it's really
nice like with the like collector versus
client because with the collector like
you want to see their piece go up in
value because that's good for you and
like they want to see you do good
because again that will make their piece
go up in value and that's good for them
so like you're very much on the same
team versus with a client
high level
you're kind of you know sort of
high-level market dynamics are against
each other a bit they're trying to get
you to do the most amount of stuff for
the least amount of money and you're
trying to do the least amount of stuff
for like the most amount of money like
that that makes it sound really kind of
like more sinister than it is but like
high level like that's kind of when you
break it down that's the way the
capitalism side of that works yeah not
that you can't have really good clients
where it's win-win but it's very much
like you guys are on the same team and
like what's good for them is like so
you're building this team of like
collectors and like people who are like
rooting for you and want to see you like
succeed and sort of like they also don't
want to see your prices go down that's
the thing
because if they buy something
and then the prices go down that
devalues the thing they already bought
so there's a lot of like kind of like
network effects in there too that's sort
of like
interesting market dynamics that can
sort of like either work to your favor
or like you know not okay so i have i
have three questions okay wow
okay so i have 37 questions go
so you
recently had a very large auction how
much did all of your pieces total sell
for so the auction was over a weekend
there was an open edition and we sold
600 pieces in the open edition for a
thousand dollars each so that was 600
000
on the like you know first night and
then there was 20 separate actually 21
separate
single edition auctions so these were
auctions where
there's just a one of one for these 20
and they were over the course of the
weekend and at the end of the weekend
the total with the open editions was 3.5
million
and that's the thing like it's what's
crazy too what's crazy too is it like
instantly is deposited so it's like my
like account balance on the site was
boom just at the end of the weekend 3.2
million dollars like right there
everybody paid 100 it's not like oh
we'll pay in two weeks or this or that
it's like boom they got their nfts money
was deposited instantly like dawn like i
mean obviously it's a huge success but
also it's like i think putting in
context here you know you've been doing
this for years releasing stuff for free
and you know this it feels almost more
like a sum of that experience kind of
all hitting rapidly in 48 hours that
could be that could be it definitely
it's like that is the culmination of all
the value you've built up from doing
this every single day for over 13 years
but going into that weekend you couldn't
have expected exactly how much all these
paintings would be sold for what were
your expectations i thought it could
have gotten a million to be honest
though because i'd seen like
other things in the space that had gone
for like pretty big amounts of money and
i'd seen i showed it to some collectors
beforehand and i could see people were
very excited about this because it was
such a like with the physical pieces
such a new sort of
way of looking at it and something that
felt like much more complete than
um you know sort of systems in the past
in terms of how the website works with
qr code and sort of the whole complete
system for
you know being able to view these pieces
and think about them in a different way
so
but
you know that was my wildest imagination
was like maybe this would go for like a
million dollars like that a million
dollars like three million dollars it's
like that was just like
insane insane but yeah celebrate what's
up what'd you do to celebrate
honestly nothing really like we really
just like started freaking working on
the next one pretty much right away i
mean they like freaking hose me down
with like you know some champagne or
something but
i feel like it kind of has it suck it
still a little bit but
there's just it was so fun to make and
so it was just kind of like
immediately it was like okay let's do
that again like that was super super fun
the like weekend was obviously super fun
and like making it was just like you
know i think people could see how much
like passion and like how much sort of
like you know inspiration went into like
the pieces and so it was just
it was super cool to see it all come
together like that but yeah we just
basically started working on the like
max purchase
so
for all your pieces from that weekend
they sold for a value of about three and
a half million dollars but that was the
value on the first sale yeah so those
like the stock market that can grow in
value do you know what the value of all
of that is now it depends on again who
wants to buy it now a lot of those
pieces like are not really sort of like
for sale it's kind of one of these
things where
people probably wouldn't buy something
especially
when you're talking about pieces that
are a hundred thousand dollars they're
not gonna buy them and like flip them
like immediately right like they'll hold
on to them so it's like who knows what
it'll be in like you know two three
years or whatever
ten years whatever yeah so it sort of
depends on
again the trajectory of me if i'm more
popular in the future then the pieces
will be worth more money if people gives
a bit about that dude and he ruined his
career on that damn corridor crew
video
yeah so then it's like okay yeah value
is freaking
torch because of you [ __ ]
so yeah it really is like kind of like
it'll go up and down just like any other
artist if some artist is popular or
whatever banksy or whoever like then the
value of the pieces go up if nobody
gives it to me
i think it's such an interesting
exciting space like i want more people
like i'm telling people because it's
sort of like it's
everybody's coming like you know like
you've talked to like 3d artists like i
can guarantee you every 3d artist will
know about crypto art in you know three
to six months yeah i'm already like
deciding to jump completely on board
with this stuff yeah i think it's a cool
like alternative way for like this art
that we've been looking you know and
making and putting like time and passion
and energy into for years and never
thought about it being able to be like
collected like now the technology is in
place for it to actually truly be
collected and it's like
well what the [ __ ] like people are gonna
make like real livings out of this [ __ ]
that like you know before it couldn't
make a living you think about like a
painter or somebody like that like if
you're a really good painter you can
make a living just selling paintings
like there will be people that try
really hard at making digital art and
they'll be able to make a living selling
it just like a painter would which was
not possible
you know three years ago or whatever two
years ago so how old is this whole idea
and the concept and the technology
behind all this are we still early
enough days or have we kind of like did
we missed the train very very early days
so this stuff actually came out in late
2017 the first project with nfts was
called crypto kitties and it was this
like kind of like tamagotchi like thing
they created the like protocol that that
you know
nfts sort of like work on on ethereum or
whatever so yeah this is very much like
at the beginning of like
this space that i personally believe
will be around for like a long time do i
know that for sure no i have absolutely
nothing no idea like who the hell knows
but i i think there's enough cool things
there to like draw in a bunch more peeps
how would this be different from just
buying the rights to an image from an
artist or is it kind of the same thing
but just done through a much more modern
system no so it's actually that's a very
interesting question i think a lot of
people assume that they own the
copyright of these pieces but they
absolutely do not the artist retains the
copyright for sure
the artist absolutely retains the
copyright and the ability to
commercially reproduce these pieces of
artwork the only thing the person who
buys the token is getting is the right
to display that token and say they own
that token that's it
they definitely are not buying the
copyright i 100 guarantee you but again
this is something that to be honest
needs to be fleshed out a bit more it's
basically all now in the terms of
service on each platform and they're
kind of slightly worded different so
but none of them are worded such that
the person buying a token
gets the copyright for sure what about
the ownership of the content within the
image
how is that being handled
because it's like like you have like
buzz lightyear in some of your images
that have you know sold for a lot so how
but like that's that's disney isn't it
so what's the deal with that it's
definitely disney but that's the thing i
think people are too
worried about that stuff because to be
quite honest there's a broad range of
like coverage that you get under fair
use as long as you're not trying to like
i'm gonna try and like counterfeit this
and like capitalize it and you know sell
this mickey thing for whatever it's like
okay well i'm clearly not doing that i'm
making a statement about mickey about
bloods light year about sort of
commercial or pop art or whatever so
there's quite a bit of protection look
at like andy warhol with the soup cans
it's literally like
it's a big soup cans i like that
all right so i'm still trying to wrap my
head around the whole concept of crypto
art and nfts it's very challenging
people himself
sat down with us and we made art
together we collaborated and did a
render challenge together and we wanted
to honor the lives lost
the suffering that people have dealt
with in the pandemic and so we're going
to be doing a crypto art auction 100 for
charity starting this wednesday
including a video dropping on the
channel where we do the render challenge
with people for that charity but if you
want to start following stuff now we
have a maker's place account we'll have
a link in the description below and
that's where the whole auction is going
to be going up we'll be having some of
our artwork as well as one of people's
pieces that he made with us going up in
that auction also the idea of being able
to look back at your digital work and
think of it more like art is really
fascinating and kind of inspiring we
have a lot of history here at corridor
this
february marks the 10-year anniversary
of the first viral video that we ever
put on the corridor channel so we're
going to be doing a 10-year
retrospective
crypto drop our very first nft drop on
maker's place this upcoming friday we'll
have a video going up on the channel
about that as well i have no idea where
it's all going but we're gonna
experiment with it stay tuned to this
channel subscribe if you haven't
follow us on instagram if you want more
frequent updates or you can go right to
the spot where it's all gonna be going
down maker's place we'll have links all
in that description if you want to go
ahead and click them